boa tarde a todos
vai falar um caminho é é aquilo que foi
a unidade não criei e criei um carinho a
vaga na zaga tirou a minha experiência
ao longo do meu tempo a fazer
voluntariado se juntaria se no banco
alimentar um disse
também fiz aqui no próprio hospital são
joão porto não gente será que um dia
teria que ainda é também com um plus né
não juntos jfs e eu aprendi muito muito
conjunto variado e achei que era uma
forma também de aprendizagem
isso tudo num curso como curso de
medicina em que é necessário uma
componente social e humana muito grande
nós muitas vezes deixando que os médicos
não ligam muito e às vezes esquece isso
outro lado está uma pessoa e assim volta
em 2010
na sequência de um despacho eleitoral eu
pensei que aumenta se a um espaço
reitora dizer que vamos avaliar uma
forma de aprendizagem porque não se
introduzir essa forma de aprendizagem
assim o grupo fez uma proposta foi em
2007 é que a natureza no curso ensina a
minha raiva é uma coisa mas infelizmente
não se encaixava bem naquilo que é a
organização é na altura mas isso nós não
estamos a preparar uma forma e nessa
altura pobre e vamos fazer essa proposta
se insista em 2014 que na proposta e
finalmente ela no chão como uma unidade
optativa entrada na altura os 11 anos
até os 12 3º ano no quarto quinto e 34
anos estão ligados a funcionar em cada
um semestre
ela faz parte da área das ciências
sociais e humanas a quatro áreas
atrativas aqui na popular e cada
estudante
é computar um certo número 10 pts em
cada uma das áreas
a idéia é promover até esta formação
social e humana mas não através de aulas
não através de cursos que às vezes
passam as nossas estão a dormir e nós
através de uma ação direta junto das
instituições de solidariedade
obrigado o estudante a ter um papel
ativo e sendo assim tornando se mais
responsável
eu sempre computar no mínimo 50 horas
uma vez que o curso o curso ensina pelo
menos 20 estão ligadas à caça um museu
na sua dimensão mais ampla e em termos
de aulas para oficialmente tem um mal um
dia na barra tem uma aula de samba de
roda quando apresento a une naval
explicam aquilo que quiser e apresenta
uma plataforma eletrônica que uso para
um deus podem escrever ou estão as ações
que objetivam executado e essa página
qual as instituições fazem avaliação de
luz e também é onde eu sou metem o
relatório
nessa reunião também faz uma pequena
reflexão sobre o que é o trabalho do
voluntariado especificamente muito
responsável e não esquecem que estão
trabalhando muitas vezes começou hoje
que alguma forma estão fragilizados e do
povo além disso ensinada conferência
levava tudo aqui o espaço especialmente
quando envolve crianças e ainda há a se
lembrar do que obrigatória comunista sua
gestão
dependendo de alguma forma estão contato
com algum time venceu falha alguma coisa
que alguém vai ficar é eu sou avaliados
até que o ator falou hoje pela
instituição com base no que foi o seu
trabalho assinada o cumprimento das
normas a respeito pelos outros numa
integração no projeto ea atenção
dispensada ao programa e depois tem
outra componente da avaliação que vai no
relatório lembrar que isto
trata de uma irá curricular integrado
num curso de um estado degradado
infinita
não é só o mundo ali a tutoriais matar
no sinal de fazerem uma reflexão sobre
aquilo que foi o trabalho e nessa altura
é o tal relatório onda entre outros
parâmetros é muito importante poderia
não façam entre o que foram as suas
expectativas iniciais e aquilo que foi
com o seu trabalho
o ano passado foi quando arrancou ontem
55 durante o primeiro semestre ele não
aumentar em 90 anos como neste ano está
em 95 estudante foi ocuparão as vagas
todas foi quanto a que tem mais
verdadeiro mestre do trabalho que eu
fico tão só muito diversificados mas com
crianças crianças na casa do ronaldo mas
não no apoio aos tudo em papel mas nem
pensa em jardins de infância então na
zona das montanhas porque é uma arma mas
eu nunca hut dificuldade é apoio aos
jovens mais mães solteiras fundo criado
nos hospitais de são joão no ipê óleo
santo antônio a o suco ritmo até mesmo
trabalhar com animais o que também é uma
questão são os por causa dos animais
abandonados é também uma questão de
saúde pública
é é a partir daqui eu tenho uma reflexão
sobre aquilo que foi expresso nos
relatórios do iphan
não sou eu que o digo são os estudantes
e os que conhecem realmente é necessário
para desenvolver as ações que desenvolve
muito que era paciência que era
compreensão a solidariedade o respeito
pelo outro atenção ou outro aprendem
acreditar fui eu acho muita piada com
um relatório um hormônio que conta que
já não importava se não treinar se
esquece aquilo era uma disciplina ou uma
unidade curricular como agora já não
substitui nada já não estamos a fish
porém nas costas é ensinar uma arrumar e
eu já não era é importante já não era
aquela unidade de cloro naquelas pessoas
que ela estava no avião havia e que
estava pendente deu e ao mesmo tempo é
psicologicamente complicado pois é quem
já fez pontaria sabem se mas ao mesmo
tempo é extremamente gratificante e isso
é algo que todos reconhecem a
notificação ao sentido de chegar à casa
cansar mas flui e ao mesmo tempo se
envolvem outras competências que nós
normalmente esquecemos isso é importante
no curso ensina muito importante mas
deveria constar em cima da outra outros
cursos que é capacidade de comunicação
capacitar o coração cada vez mais na
frente e ele estava que era ser muita
gente para conseguir desenvolver aqui é
um trabalho que precisa também da
natação nós precisamos nos adaptar aos
vários desafios neste momento estamos
preparados para áreas para as quais nem
sequer sabemos um parceiro interessante
ver que os reconhecem que ganhou
maturidade porque há obrigatoriamente
vão ter que lutar passada os seus
limites vão estar para as situações que
ignoravam que não cena de ver um idoso
deitado numa cama rodeado por amigos e
insetos e ratos que não passar porque o
tento assinalado que a família precisa
receber o dinheiro para poder manter é
complicado e muitas vezes as pessoas não
estão preparadas para verificar a chuva
passar somente os homens - e aprender
razoável os outros aprenderam também
deverá ser mais organizados por que o
universo foi clara exigente tem que
dispensar muitas horas e foi preciso
organizar melhor o seu tempo e uma coisa
muito importante
saber ouvir os outros saíram dos seus
problemas e saber conversar é élson
frase que eu queria que eu quero passar
para chamar um pouco a atenção daquilo
que foi o trabalho de hoje todos nós
mesmos não ser médico podem ter um papel
importante no tratamento das pessoas
isto é eu acho que é extremamente
importante e obstruírem está ainda no
início do curso em que a rádio as formas
realmente do tratado o que virá aqui é
um estudante que estava fazendo 11
thiago aquino ipioca estava para
enfrentar o isolamento o tempo que o
equipamento próprio que as crianças
estão com umidade baixa e acho que a
jovem então pronto para jogar na bola e
ela pensava
vamos ter que jogar pois taxa e quando
esta está uma rapariga linha toda
equipada com rola no futebol eu passar
toda fazendo guarda a gente ia sofrer
gols
combine aquela casa cheia de violência
mas não alcançadas defendendo se atirar
no chão mas ao menos já que a rapariga
estava em isolamento não tinha mais
ninguém sua mãe estava feliz e se
prendem com o dom de ouvir conhecer as
pessoas saberão que a fazer com o
marcelinho e tratado é hoje que é muito
importante está com a que os pais a quem
o filho está muito difícil
afinal o camisa 9 18 20 anos e tenham
capaz de sair conta a história que tinha
voltado da cunha e e supostamente dada
como curada agora é uma caída
difícil será para contactar com a
realidade destas e sim fazer com que a
sociedade outra forma ano da história
também num uma rapariga
fazer aqui na porta solidária numa tese
em que estavam assistindo refeições a
pessoas carenciadas e algumas pessoas só
queriam uma sopa não ganha o pão ea uns
um cãozinho lá é que não tem dente não
posso comer é o confronto que é com esta
realidade é que a pessoa faça um grande
dificuldade e que o fato simples fato de
os dois estarem estragados é suficiente
para quem grandes dificuldades para
inserir seus alimentos e pancadas chicos
podem fazer toda a diferença
uma simples conversa 15 sorriso ou por
simplesmente substituir uma mãe cuidando
do bebê está ligado a um conjunto de
máquinas ea mensagem que ele jogue
se alguma máquina picada pintar muito
tempo a agência mensagem pra finalmente
poderá estar a ter um cantinho do céu
tempo poder descansar e ver um café e
aquela nos ensina a pensar que já sabe
muito pensar sozinho com um bebê ligava
conjunto máquinas que não param de fazer
os seus barulhos sem saber o que quer
fazer todo o negócio porque se alguma
delas tocar e não precisa controlar duas
horas que aproveitou contratados vão
procurar mais com ela disse
no fim do dia é que eu postei difícil é
para os pais é que o momento em que
estão doentes e que estão a sós enfim
não tem ninguém que realmente disse que
no final da estação todos pensámos o
perfil médio queremos dias e é porque
ouviram uma pessoa que estava aqui no
hospital e que me jovem não esqueça
quando for médica que nós precisamos
conversar
nós precisamos ser ouvinte as coisas e
acho que isso é algo que é impossível
transmitir não pela vivência
- isso é algo que é ao longo das várias
unidades foi pular san sisto quando é
feita a seleção dos novos estudantes nós
falamos de curar pessoas não é só pra
doenças é preciso atender a chance irá
se completa de cada um dos doentes que
estão à nossa frente é e e isto eu se
observam porque vão vivenciar por
conquistar com carros muitas vezes não
imaginavam ser impossíveis e esta fase
da guarda que nunca imaginaria ansr uma
semana em frente daquela consulta lago
montaria o dia 12 a mais que o segundo
semestre e que quando terminou terminou
de uma forma de frente e tantas outras
rochas por exemplo quando foi embora na
apresentação da no novo texto no ano em
que eu convidar em alguns dos que
tiveram no ano lectivo anterior
eu lembro um dos dos colegas crava o
exemplo que se tinha passado com erro
num nas montanhas em que assistiu a
criança estava toda a destroçar o pai
estava preso a mãe não sabia onde estava
e ele e com sua avó
ninguém não tem ninguém com ela e é
perder em algum do seu tempo a ensinar
nunca em matemática e português que ela
ia seria continuar sempre como ficou lá
deixar a alegria que se prevê muito sem
ser necessário estas aulas formais para
que alguém pra falar que é um exemplo
num feriado isto não seria apenas para a
faculdade
assim eu acho que estaria sensível a
qualquer curso é qualquer um
é conscientizar junto não sabe completar
condições mas é qualquer um nós tem
muito a aprender pelo como um telhado e
ampliem esta palavra que eu dizia não é
à toa que as empresas cada vez mais
valorizou no rei com um cada um note o
ter escutado obrigado para que possam
contrariado que um precisa todos falsos
muito obrigado